u.s president joe biden has announced
sweeping new measures to combat what he
calls the pandemic of the unvaccinated
vaccinations will now be mandatory for
millions of u.s workers only just over
half of american adults are fully
immunized and that has had deadly
consequences with covert 19 cases on the
rise fueled by the delta variant
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
an exasperated president lays out his
new plan to vaccinate the almost 80
million americans still holding out
i will sign an executive order
that will now require all executive
branch federal employees to be
vaccinated all
i've signed another executive order that
will require federal contractors
to do the same
if you want to work with the federal
government do business with us get
vaccinated
vaccines will be mandatory for
healthcare workers in federally funded
facilities
in addition staff at companies with more
than 100 employees must now be
vaccinated or tested weekly and offered
paid leave to get the jab
the new rules will impact two-thirds of
all workers in the
u.s president biden also announced
greater access to testing and harsher
fines for not wearing masks
the day before the president's
announcement
over 1500 people in the u.s died from
covert 19.
but republican opponents of the
president have criticized his plan as
unconstitutional they say biden is using
fear and control and that the new
measures will cause workplace
discrimination
how the government will enforce the
mandates is yet to be seen and legal
challenges are expected
but for now the message is clear the
white house is done waiting for
americans to make up their minds
ntw stephen simons is following this
story in washington d.c we asked him
earlier how the new rules will be
implemented
of course the labor department as you as
you heard will now
force and urge strongly urge businesses
over 100 people who employ more than 100
people to
mandate vaccination of those workers or
get tested once a week you can bet that
this will end up in courts because the
question is is this actually legal
constitutional can the president do this
can the labor department the federal
labor department order private
businesses to mandate their workers to
be vaccinated that's an open question
but whatever he can do whatever this
administration can do they will do now
and
you know there are people here to say
this is just the first step to a
nationwide mandatory vaccination effort
which will come if the numbers don't
improve how will this be enforced good
question i don't think we have the
answer for this yet
you